so we're told that Amanda young wants to
win some prizes a cereal company is
giving away a prize in each box of
cereal and they advertise collect all
six prizes each box of cereal has one
prize and each prize is equally likely
to appear in any given box
Amanda wonders how many boxes it takes
on average to get all six prizes so
there's several ways to approach this
for Amanda she could try to figure out a
mathematical way to determine what is
the expected number of boxes she would
need to collect on average to get all
six prizes or she could run some random
numbers to simulate collecting box after
box after box and figure out multiple
trials on how many boxes to take to win
all six prizes so for example she could
say all right each box is going to have
one of six prizes so there could be she
could assign a number for each of the
prizes one two three four five six and
then she could have a computer generate
a random string of numbers maybe
something that looks like this and the
general method she could start at the
left here and each new number she gets
she can say hey this is like getting a
cereal box and then it's going to tell
me which prize I got so she starts her
first experiment she'll start here at
the left and so say okay the first
cereal box of this experiment of this
simulation
I got prize number one and she'll keep
going the next one she gets prize number
five then the third one she gets prize
number six then the fourth one she gets
prize number six again and she will keep
going until she gets all six prizes you
might say well look their numbers here
that aren't one through six there's zero
there's seven there's eight or nine well
for those numbers she could just ignore
them she could just pretend like they
aren't there and just keep going past
them so why don't you pause this video
and do it for the first experiment on
this first experiment using these
numbers assuming that this is the FIR
box that you are getting in your
simulation how many boxes would you need
in order to get all six prizes so let's
let me make a table here so this is the
experiment and then in the second column
I'm going to say number of boxes number
of boxes you would have to get in that
simulation so maybe I'll do the first
one in this blue color so we're in the
first simulation so one box we got the
one and actually maybe I'll check things
off so we have to get a 1 a 2 a 3 a 4 a
5 and a 6 so let's see we have a 1 I'll
check that off we have a 5 I'll check
that off we get a 6 I'll check that off
well the next box we got another 6 we've
already have that prize we're going to
keep getting boxes then the next box we
get a 2 then the next box we get a 4
then the next box the numbers of 7 so we
will just ignore this right over here
the box after that we get a 6 but we
already have that prize then we ignore
the next box is 0 that doesn't give us a
prize we assume that that doesn't that
didn't even happen and then we would go
to the number 3 which is the last prize
that we need so how many boxes did we
have to go through well we would only
count the valid one the ones that gave a
valid prize between the numbers 1
through 6 including 1 and 6 so let's see
we went through 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 boxes in
the first experiment so experiment
number one it took us eight boxes to get
all six prizes let's do another
experiment because this doesn't tell us
that on average she would expect eight
boxes just just meant that on this first
experiment it took eight boxes if you
wanted to figure out on average you want
to do many experiments and the more
experiments you do the better that that
average is going to the more likely that
your average is going to predict what it
actually takes on average to get all six
prizes so now let's do our second
experiment in a river
it's important these are truly random
numbers and so we will now start at the
first valid number so we have a two so
this is our second experiment we got it
- we got a 1 we can ignore this 8 then
we get a 2 again we've already have that
prize ignore the 9 5 that's the prize we
need in this experiment 9 we can ignore
and then 4 haven't gotten that prize yet
in this experiment 3 haven't gotten that
prize yet in this experiment 1 we
already got that prize 3 we already got
that prize three already got fries - 2
already got those prizes 0 we actually
got all of these prizes over here we can
ignore the 0 already got that prize and
finally we get prize number 6 so how
many boxes did we need in that second
experiment let's see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 boxes so an
experiment - I needed 17 or Amanda
needed 17 boxes and she can keep going
let's do this one more time
this is strangely fun so experiment 3
remember we only want to look at the
valid numbers we'll ignore the invalid
numbers the ones that don't give us a
valid prize number so 4 we get that
prize these are all invalid in fact and
then we go to 5 we get that prize 5 we
already have it we get the two prize 7
and 8 are invalid sevens and valid 6 we
get that prize sevens invalid 1 we got
that prize 1 we already got it 9s
invalid - we already got it
9 is invalid 1 we already got the one
prize and then finally we get prize
number three which was the missing prize
so how many boxes valid boxes do we have
did we have to go through let's see 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10 so it's only 3
experiments what was our average well
with these three experiments our average
is going to be 8 plus 17 plus 10 over 3
so let's see this is 25 35 over 3 which
is equal to 11 and 2/3 now do we know
that this is the true theoretical
expected number of boxes that you would
need to get no we don't know that but
the more experiments we run the closer
our average is likely get to the true
theoretical average